on the surface business appears to be
booming but this is only part of
lebanon's reality income inequality is
not new in a country where the richest
10 percent of the population owns almost
70 percent of the total wealth
but now the economy has collapsed making
the poor even more vulnerable it's being
blamed on a system put in place by the
political and business Elite who are
refusing reforms to fight corruption the
state is nearly bankrupt the public
sector right now has no revenue and you
know you need to pay salaries to public
employees for them to go to work we are
witnessing increasingly closing down of
public institutions
professors at the Lebanese universities
are no longer going to work
[Music]
people are desperate some have stormed
banks at times armed demanding their own
money their savings have been trapped by
informal Capital controls since the
onset of the economic crisis
lebanon's financial crisis entered its
fourth year with losses amounting to
more than 70 billion dollars the World
Bank says the country's current and
future state-owned assets public real
estate potential but uncertain oil and
gas revenues combined are worth only a
fraction of that
the political paralysis hasn't helped a
fragmented Parliament hasn't been able
to elect a president since November and
without a head of state A government
can't be formed it's an unprecedented
vacuum that delays efforts to revive the
economy
there are people who are sleeping
without dinner they don't have money to
buy food there are no jobs graduates are
trying to find a way out of the country
there's little to show for the billions
of dollars spent over the decades that's
apart from The Chronic mismanagement
nothing will change even if they elect a
president because the same politicians
responsible for running the economy into
the ground are still in power
there's been no accountability for a
crisis that's destroyed the lives of so
many instead Lebanon has become a failed
State Beirut